cuáles de los triángulos de f g h i j k
l son similares al triángulo abc y por
supuesto aquí nos marcaron este ángulo
este ángulo de aquí nos lo marcaron y
también nos dan los lados de este de
este triángulo abc ok y quizás recuerdes
de clase de geometría que puedes
demostrar que dos triángulos son
similares si tienen ángulos
correspondientes congruentes y sus lados
adyacentes son proporcionales muy bien
es decir que la proporción entre los
lados correspondientes
es la misma entonces vamos a ver cuáles
de estos triángulos son similares por
ejemplo vamos a empezar con el triángulo
en este triángulo j k l muy bien y nos
dan aquí este ángulo de hecho nos lo dan
en todos lados verdad estos ángulos que
oportunamente ya están marcados y nos
indican que son iguales a este que nos
dieron entonces lo que nosotros tenemos
que ver es qué pasa con la proporción de
los lados adyacentes verdad
correspondientes y ver si tienen la
misma
porción entonces voy a elegir por
ejemplo qué pasaría con este lado este
lado del triángulo abc mide 3 raíz de 2
entonces con cuál sería correspondiente
en este caso
bueno pues sería correspondiente a este
y tú te preguntarás hoy y cómo fue que
te decidiste este y no por ejemplo este
bueno pensemos que este otro lado el
lado de a que este lado vea es mucho más
grande que el lado bc entonces tiene que
ser correspondiente con el lado más
grande en este otro triángulo entonces
de esta forma es que yo pude elegir con
cuáles serían nuestros cuáles serían los
candidatos para ser proporcionales muy
bien ahora el detalle es que aquí no nos
dan las medidas sobre las distancias de
estos segmentos pero lo que sí nos dan
son estos triángulos localizados en el
plano cartesiano así que lo que vamos a
tener que usar es la fórmula de la
distancia que esencialmente es aplicar
el teorema de pitágoras para saber qué
distancia
o qué longitud tienen estos segmentos
muy bien entonces vamos a hacerlo por
ejemplo este este lado acá j este es el
lado acá j y lo podemos poner como la
hipotenusa de este triángulo rectángulo
muy bien y este tiene una altura de tres
cuadritos son es una altura de tres
mientras que de base tiene 123456789
nueve unidades de base
ahora si tú quieres utilizar por ejemplo
la fórmula de la distancia al cuadrado
esencialmente esto es el cambio en x
verdad entonces nosotros tenemos que
este triángulo tiene este vértice perdón
el vértice j tiene tiene coordenada x
igual a 3 mientras que el vértice que
tiene coordenada en x igual a menos 6
entonces de hecho el 9 se puede calcular
como 3 menos menos 6 verdad pero bueno
es más fácil verlo así con este
triángulo entonces vamos a tratar de
calcular cuál es la longitud de esta
distancia
entonces tenemos que la longitud de kj
lo podemos calcular usando el teorema de
pitágoras es decir este cateto al
cuadrado más el otro cateto al cuadrado
es igual a la longitud de kj al cuadrado
muy bien esto quién es esto es 3 al
cuadrado es 99 por 9 281 y esto es kj al
cuadrado ahora 9 más 81 son 90 entonces
dejan a cambiarlo de orden simplemente
kj al cuadrado será 81 más 9 que son 90
y que esto es 9 por 10 ahora por qué
porque los separe así pues porque quiero
sacar raíz cuadrada entonces la longitud
de cada jota es la raíz cuadrada de 9
por 10 y haberlo separado así me permite
poner esto como 3 raíz de 10 muy bien
entonces esta longitud es de 3 raíz de
10 vamos a ver qué pasa con la longitud
azul
vamos a construir otro triángulo
así es otro triángulo rectángulo para
poder calcular la longitud y ésta tiene
el lado 3 esta tiene o bueno en este
caso sería la base y la altura es 3 así
que si queremos calcular esta longitud
de azul tenemos 3 al cuadrado más 3 al
cuadrado es igual a la longitud kl al
cuadrado muy bien o si hacemos esta
operación esto es 9 verdad y esto
también lo que nos da 18 y esto es kl al
cuadrado es decir raíz de 18 es igual a
kl y 18 lo podemos ver como 4 no más
bien 9 por 2 verdad 9 por 2 y la raíz
cuadrada en 9 straits y que multiplica
la raíz cuadrada de 2 muy bien entonces
ya tenemos estos dos lados ahora podemos
tratar de ver cómo es la proporción
entre sus lados de hecho no tenemos nada
que ver verdad de hecho son iguales
aquí tenemos 3 raíz de 2 y este
a raíz de dos mientras que el otro es
tres raíz de 10 y éste es 3 raíz de 10
entonces de hecho no sólo son no sólo
son similares sino todavía más son
triángulos congruentes entonces este
triángulo este triángulo perdón es
congruente al triángulo abc muy bien
vamos a ver qué pasa con el triángulo y
perdón d
efe muy bien entonces otra vez tenemos
nuestro ángulo aquí ya marcado vamos a
elegir el lado más grande como el que
podría ser similar o más bien
proporcional al lado rojo que es el ave
mientras que el otro el lado
efe podría hacer
correspondiente al lado veces muy bien
entonces construimos nuevamente no estos
nuestros triángulos y aquí por ejemplo
este triángulo va a ser muy fácil de
calcular porque tiene de longitud 1 y 1
muy bien entonces la longitud del
segmento
efe al cuadrado es este es uno al
cuadrado más uno al cuadrado es la
longitud de e
efe al cuadrado o en otras palabras
efe es la raíz cuadrada de uno más uno
que es la raíz cuadrada de dos muy bien
vamos a ver qué pasa con el segmento ed
y para eso podemos construir nuestro
triángulo rectángulo de esta forma muy
bien que tiene la 21 y tiene altura 3
muy bien entonces la longitud de ed será
1 al cuadrado más 3 al cuadrado será ed
al cuadrado muy bien así es como lo
calculamos
podemos decir que 1 al cuadrado es 13 al
cuadrado es 9 y que por lo tanto ed es
la raíz cuadrada de de 19 que es 10
entonces esto es la raíz cuadrada de 10
muy bien ahora como sabe esto sí queda
claro que no son iguales pero queremos
ver la proporción entonces tenemos por
ejemplo el lado b se tiene 3 raíz de 2 y
si lo dividimos entre el lado
correspondiente que es el ef sería
dividir entre raíz de 2 y la proporción
nos queda 3 muy bien vamos a ver si
coincide con la otra por proporción
cuánto mide el lado b a mide 3 raíz de
10 y si lo dividimos entre lo
correspondiente con el lado de que es
raíz de 10 nos queda que la proporción
es 3 entonces fueron iguales estas
proporciones y por lo tanto este
triángulo de
también es similar al abc ahora solo nos
queda un caso vamos a ver primero
identificamos los lados correspondientes
aquí nos dan el ángulo que en el que
coinciden y el lado b c será
correspondiente al lado y h que hay aquí
este lado y h y el lado ave será
correspondiente al lado
hg muy bien ahí ya ya quedó marcado como
calculamos otra vez esta distancia bueno
construimos los triángulos ahí lo tienen
este tiene base 2 y altura 2 mientras
que éste tiene altura 1 2 3 4 5 6 es
christine altura 6 y de base tiene 2 muy
bien entonces como calculamos la
longitud del y h pues esto será 2 al
cuadrado más 2 al cuadrado es la
longitud del y h al cuadrado ahora 2 al
cuadrado es 4 así que esto simplemente
es 8 es la longitud d
y h al cuadrado y por lo tanto podríamos
pensar de hecho podemos garantizar que
la raíz cuadrada de 8 es la longitud y h
muy bien ahora bien 8 lo podemos ver
como 2 por 4 y por lo tanto su raíz
cuadrada es 2 raíz de 2
esto es y h muy bien ahora vamos a ver
qué ocurre con el segmento hg hg hg al
cuadrado será 2 al cuadrado más 6 al
cuadrado y esto será hg al cuadrado
ahora esto es 4 esto es 4 y 6 al
cuadrado es 36 muy bien
hg al cuadrado es 36 más 4 36 más 4 es
40 entonces déjame ponerlo así hg será
la raíz cuadrada de 4 36 que es 40 muy
bien y esto el 40 lo podemos ver como 4
por 10 ya esto le sacamos raíz cuadrada
entonces hg esencialmente es la raíz de
4 que es 2
la raíz de 10 muy bien entonces ahora
otra vez tenemos que calcular estas
proporciones entonces el lado b se mide
3 raíz de 2 y dividimos entre el lado y
h que es 2 raíz de 2 entonces al
dividirlo nos quedan 3 medios vamos a
ver qué ocurre con con el lado b a con
respecto al hg el lado b a mide 3 raíz
de 10 y dividimos entre hg que es 2 raíz
de 10 muy bien y estos se cancelan y
otra vez nos volvió a quedar que la
proporción es la misma y qué sorpresa
verdad ahora resulta que estos tres
triángulos fueron similares
al triángulo abc y por lo tanto son
similares entre ellos